baba ahmed merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors les
manifestations contre ibrahim boubacar
kéïta on le disait se poursuivre
qu'est-il reproché précisément au
président en place
alors la contestation est partie des
élections législatives qui se sont
tenues au mois de mars dernier et au
cours de ces élections s'étaient maligne
parce que les voix des électeurs n'ont
pas été respectées et beaucoup de
contestations au niveau notamment de
bamako mais aussi au niveau de la de
l'intérieur des pays comme les centres
du mali ou encore des régions et du seed
com sikasso qui sonde habituel des
régions beaucoup cale où il n'ya pas des
manifestations alors pourquoi les
opposants ne veulent pas accepter la
proposition du président à savoir la
mise en place d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
alors c'est qui est clair c'est que pour
le moment les opposants n'ont pas encore
répondu à l'appel à 7 mai tandis du
président ils n'ont pas encore répondu
également assez à ce qu'ils avancent
aujourd'hui à ce qu'ils offrent
aujourd'hui une rencontre était prévue
la semaine dernière entre le président
et les mouvements du 5 juin
elle les organisateurs ont refusé passé
ils disent qu'ils ne veulent pas aller à
rencontrer le président de père de
démobiliser les partisans qui est donc
qui ont qui sont sortis hier vendredi et
très probablement
c'est ce week end où d'ici la semaine
prochaine on aura une rencontre
officielle entre le président et les
contestataires
donc cette perspective d'union nationale
elle est possible aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les grands problèmes
aujourd'hui pour les politiciens
ce n'est pas cette union nationale ce
qui aujourd'hui et ils ont un problème
avec ce qu'on a avec la cour
constitutionnelle au mali la cour
constitutionnelle c'est elle qui valide
les élections et donc après avoir
regardé les inégalités et tous et
comment est-ce que l'organisation a été
fait de faire aujourd'hui les
politiciens aujourd'hui il on perd parce
que les élections présidentielles au
mali
et dans deux ans c'est en 2023 donc des
dents dans deux ans et demi et ils ont
peur d'aller vers une élection où la
cour constitutionnelle va probablement
franchir pour les candidats de la
majorité ou de ceux qui sont au pouvoir
est en réalité c'est ça la paire
aujourd'hui qui mobilise société civile
et partis politiques et donc du coup
aujourd'hui on est dans une
constestation à la réalité
ceux ci pour avoir ce pour aller vers
cette élection de 2000 28 élections
présidentielles de 2000 23 août chacun a
sa chance de gagner et non pas une
élection où la cour constitutionnelle
malgré les votes des maliens peu penché
pour pour pour un candidat
alors quels sont les figures qui se
détache de ce mouvement de contestation
il y a un nom qui revient celui d'un
imam mahmoud dicko qui est il c'est un
imam qui qui dirige lui comme lui-même
se qualifie il dirige la prière labeaume
en cours depuis 40 ans c'est quelqu'un
il incarne cette société civile qui a
acquis aux aguets qui au sursaut un peu
à l'image de ce qui se passe au congo
avec les églises donc il est dans cette
dynamique là aujourd'hui et à chaque
fois que ce que les maliens souffrent de
l'insécurité ou qui souffrent de la
crise sécuritaire où la crise
alimentaire ou à ce moment la crise
politique
ils servent sur ces contestations pour
pour appeler les maliens à manifester et
je vous rappelle que a déjà déjà en 2009
c'est-à-dire ya onze ans de cela l'imam
ce même l'imam dicko a réussi à
rassembler dans un stade à bamako plus
de 500 plus de 50000 personnes c'est
énorme
au mali sous d'autres cieux peut être se
peut mais au mali c'est un homme pour
pour obliger le gouvernement malien a
reculé suite suite à un code des
personnes et de la famille qui donne
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup davantage
aux femmes et donc depuis lors à chaque
fois que il pense que le gouvernement du
mali est en déphasage avec la société
malienne
ils servent sur cette vague là pour pour
faire des manifestations et pour obliger
le gouvernement du mali a à prendre des
décisions qui des décisions au bénéfice
de la population pour conclure en
quelques mots on le sait le mali
confronté depuis 2012 à la menace
djihadiste il ya deux jours le président
de l'assemblée nationale
moussa tine guinée a mis en garde
beaucoup de ceux qui marchent contre le
président en place sont des jihadistes
est ce que c'est le cas selon vous c'est
en fait cédé moussa houmous est le
président de l'assemblée mons a terminé
lui même est contestée parce qu'il a été
élu dans des circonstances où allah ou
les premiers résultats provisoires au
lieu de lui donne comme vin cuit mais la
cour constitutionnelle a en tout cas il
a été déclaré vainqueur à partir de la
cour constitionnelle donc lui même il
sait où il se trouve dans une position
très fragile à part cette contestation
ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des choses il est très
difficile aujourd'hui de prouver ce
qu'il dit il était difficile de prouver
que parmi les manifestants il y avait
des dialyses et et c'est difficile
encore de prouver que même les gens ont
participé ou roux où sont mêlés à des
actions terroristes dans les centraux
dans le nord c'est mieux sur ce qu' il
ya des religieux des sympathisants de
mamoud diko qui ont qui ont une qui ont
in qui sont dans un courant religieux
sunnite un peu comme à wahhabite et qui
était dans ces manifestations
merci jusqu'à dire que ces gens sont des
djihadistes s'est quand même dit des
choses où on n'a pas de preuves
merci beaucoup baba ahmed d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journal